THE MORNING OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE. FOR
THIRSTY FOR WHERE
IT IS HEREBY CALLED ORTOFON
PIECE HERE BISON AUDIO VIDEO
RECORDS PLEASE PROCEED MADE
SALSA MEAN TELEVISED. OF MEN
SECTOR FEES CULTURAL COOLEY HERE
CUNNINGHAM ALAN. BURROUGHS.
CARILLO PRESIDENT SURVIVED AS
HERE. FRIEDMAN GRAYSON HERE AS
AREA SOLACE
DOESN'T WALDRON.
HERE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM. OF WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA DISPLACED IS OUR
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
MOVE A MUSCLE CELLS SECONDED
WEBSTER CUNNINGHAM.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY. AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE
ALLEN BROUGH CARILLO AYE GLORIA
AYE CERVANTES AYE.
AND HIS EYES FRIEDMAN GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE NOSE AREA SOLACE.
SOLIS I WALDRON AYE WALDRON AYE.
VERY GOOD OF THE MOTION IS
PASSED AND RULES COMMITTEES